The president of the United States has had
a tweet flagged by Twitter because it is encouraging
people not to vote by telling them things
that are not true about Corona virus.
This is incredible.
The sitting president of the United States
is violating the terms of service of a social
media platform, not for something unrelated
to his election, but because he is spreading
disinformation about his own upcoming reelection.
Donald Trump tweeted, quote, So now the Democrats
are using mail drop boxes, which are a voter
security disaster.
Now, of course, these are municipalities using
the boxes.
It's not Democrats.
Trump goes on to say, among other things,
they make it possible for for a person to
vote multiple times.
Also, who controls them?
Are they placed in Republican or Democrat
areas?
They are not corvids sanitized.
A big fraud.
And rightly, Twitter.
Put the message up on the tweet, which says
this tweet violated the Twitter rules about
civic and election integrity.
So there are really two parts here.
The first is Donald Trump is continuing to
say that vote by mail, absentee Dropbox's,
none of it is secure.
This is not true.
Trump is saying that without evidence.
I'm sure you know that by now.
Part two of this is this new idea of playing
on people's fears of corona virus by saying,
you know, the drop boxes for the ballots,
they're not coded, sanitized.
And this is a clear attempt to dissuade Biden
voters.
How do we know that?
Because Biden voters we know are taking coronavirus
more seriously than our Trump voters.
Biden voters are more likely to be planning
to vote by mail to avoid maybe catching Corona
virus at a polling place.
Biden voters are more likely to wear masks
when they go outside.
So we know that if you start spreading the
idea, the ballot Dropbox might give you the
virus.
You are going to disproportionately hit Biden
voters.
But it could backfire if Democrats are more
likely not to believe what Trump says.
And Trump voters are more likely to believe
what Donald Trump says.
It's conceivable that this idea of saying,
you know, you could get coronavirus from the
Dropbox.
It might end up keeping his own voters at
home.
I don't think in the end it will have a hugely
disproportionate impact one way or the other.
But Twitter is completely correct to flag
his tweet and to put a warning on it.
Donald Trump is terrified that people are
going to come out and vote in huge numbers
and not for him, but for the other guy.
And in fact, the entire Republican Party is
terrified of that.
I expect that as the election gets closer,
Trump is going to be going even crazier and
pulling out all the stops.
Everything will be on the table.
We have to make sure it backfires.
We have to keep publicizing that he's doing
this because there's one thing we know.
People will be more determined to vote.
The more they realize Trump doesn't want them
to.
People are just like that by nature.
The post office was a turning point for many
Americans.
Sending troops into cities was a turning point
for many Americans.
This is a cult.
It's a dangerous one.
And a lot of people, understandably, would
crawl over broken glass to vote in November.
The president of the United States is trying
to suppress the vote.
Obviously, he should have long ago been banned
from Twitter, regularly bullying people, breaking
just about every term and condition they have.
But this is bigger than Twitter.
Mail in ballots or bad ballot drop boxes could
be infected with coronavirus.
We have to stop it.
And you listen.
Let's skip it.
You know what
you have
to do.